- Ces radars sont les yeux
du Canada sur l'Arctique
depuis la fin des années 80.
Leur technologie est dépassée.
ANITA ANAND, ministre,
Défense nationale
- La mise à niveau de
nos infrastructures est
plus urgente que jamais.
- Ottawa va dépenser
4,9 milliards de dollars pour
déployer un nouveau système
de radar qui sera reààà
un système de surveillance
par satellite et un réseau
de capteurs sous-marins,
notamment.
- Et pour accér r r la réponse
à toute forme d'intrusion,
des airs ou de la mer,
les centres de contrôle
seront aussi à la fine pointe
de la technologie.
"Le monde a changé le 24 février
dernier avec l'invasion russe
en Ukraine", dit la ministre.
"La menace sur l'Arctique,
aussi", répond le commandant
adjoint de NORAD.
ALAIN PELLETIER, Commandement,
déf. aérospatiale, Amérique Nord
- Nous demeurons concernés
par l'évolution de la menace
principalement l'évolution
de la menace qui est présentée
par les missiles de croisières
qui sont en développement
et qui sont présentement
dans l'inventaire de
nos compétiteurs.
STÉPHANE ROUSSEL, prof. Elelele
nationale d'admin. publique
- Dès le début de la guerre,
des gens, il y a une partie
de la population, s'inquiétaient
pour la sécurité dans
l'Arctique canadien.
- Attendue depuis longtemps,
l'annonce n'étonne pas.
Pas plus que le moment
choisir r r la faire.
- Chacun s'est mis à regarder
ses vulnérabilités. Chacun
s'est mis à voir en quoi
la Russie pourrait porter
atte   à ses intérêts.
- À partir du moment où on doit
avoir une protection, on n'est
pas là.- La faiblesse du plan
de modernisation, selon
l'opposition conservatrice,
c'est la réticence du
gouvernement à pciciciper
au bouclier antimissile
américain.
PIERRE PAUL-HUS, député, PCC
Charlesbourg, QC
- On voit actuellement
que tout est possible avec
les Russes entre autres.
On pourrait être défendus
dans logogogramme antimissile,
alors que là, ce n'est pas
le cas actuellement.
Et les Américains ont été
clairs. Les Américains ont dit :
"On va se protéger en premier,
on verra si on peut protéger
le Canada."
- Les pressions vont être
certainement grandes...
- Pour le major à la retraite,
Richard Blanchette, le bouclier
antimissile devra être
la prochaine étape si
le Canada veut vraiment assurer
sa souveraineté dans le nord.
RICHARD BLANCHETTE, major-
général à la retraite et expert,
Coll. militaire royal, St-Jean
- Il faut vraiment qu'il y ait
une bonne coopération entre
les États-Unis et le Canada si
on veut que la défense de NORAD
soit aussi efficace que
possible.
- La ministre rappelle qu'il
s'agit du plan de modernisation
le  plus ambitieux des quatre
dernières décennies. Mais pour
le moment, Ottawa donne peu
de détailst t t sur les